some people think God created the
universe some people think nothing
created the universe which is the
funniest
guess and the nothing people make fun of
the God people they say God doesn't
exist I'm like okay maybe but you know
what definitely doesn't exist
nothing that's the defining
characteristic of nothing is that it
doesn't exist so what are we talking
about either you think it's God
something you can't see touch taste
photograph and science can't prove or
you think it's nothing something you
can't see touch taste photograph and
science can't prove but I think we can
all agree if nothing if you're nothing
sometimes spontaneously erupts into
everything that's a pretty goddamn
magical [__] nothing you
guys and ask ask the nothing people what
happens when you die they'll tell you
nothing you go into nothing I'm like you
mean you merge back with your
creator that's Heaven
[__]